oh hello I'm Gavin I'm Dan we're the
slow mo guys and once again it's June I
thought we've done every iteration of
giant balloon pops you thought we had I
had come up with a lot of other ideas
that potentially were very expensive to
make or dangerous or very dangerous but
we do have that probe lens that we've
used a couple of times and it's
waterproof so you want to what you want
to do you want to stick the program into
the balloon I want to probe the balloon
and inside the balloon
I want a load of water and one Daniel
Gruchy so I have to like live in the
balloon yeah we have to sort of design a
way for you to stay inside there for
longer than what thirty seconds I think
is your total dive time in balloons I
mean I was before yeah so I'm gonna have
like a snorkel and stuff ready to go in
and I thought that the best one for this
because we want as much light
penetrating the balloon as possible
would be to either use a white balloon
or a clear balloon and thankfully we did
by a giant clear balloon this one about
three years ago it's it's like is it
it's completely melted together Senna
honestly the Texas summers of my garage
have not been kind to this one yeah
we've got another replacement that we
have a spare Suns a little bit in and
out today so we've got a light dance
just sitting it up
I've also bagged the entire Phantom all
right down explain how you're gonna
breathe once you're in the balloon
essentially with great difficulty
because obviously put it around the
problem with not being able to breathe
underwater I have to get into the
balloon with this scuba gap this is
basically a scuba mask with a dishwasher
waste pipe attached to the top of it
it's secured with gaffer tape yep so as
you do very very secure the good thing
about it is it has rubber end so it sort
of attaches hopefully with a good seal
got a slight sound side-effect as well
if you ever stop hearing that noise it's
because I'm drowning you need to pop it
all right
oh okay is it is it nice and cool it's
pretty cool I don't know how you're
gonna do it like this through the side
plate yeah oh bloody expose it good nuts
[Laughter]
put it on some men's trousers
yup now you're like a genie that rolled
over fell over the lamp fell over these
guys pretties committed
Oh Joe give me wit pie and then once
obscured in just like hold it tight and
then you're gonna have to get the hose
and I can hold it with my hand tight
it's weird getting instructions from
someone who looks like a ping pong bat
can you imagine if Google Earth just
happened to fly over right now alien
human hot water balls spotted yeah can
you talk to me through it why can't you
play like if there's no clues that it's
not drowning I'll just pop it how get
rid of this it snapped go hang up well
it'll float and if you keep your hand
over that bit it won't it won't pop
anything by accident it's sharp look
give it quick quick give it to me
you are rubbish where did you come up
with that we need the hole here okay you
gotta push me from the back of my neck
to secure the water that's it push it
that's good and what if you get in there
and your snorkel has popped out you're
gonna put it in and blow the water out
okay
[Music]
Haggar dad you see that oh yeah I didn't
realize that was a thing so we have to
pull the top off okay it's day two new
balloon got some better waterproofing on
the Phantom it's just a splash bag
really and and we've rectified a slight
breathing issue and the the slight
breathing issue I didn't it actually
works down about that time hm it's sort
of white and transparent it looks way
worse around your leg right out did I
put in some extra pounds since yesterday
quesadillas Casey yep my beer get some
real James Buckley vibes for this okay I
think this video is gonna make people
really uncomfortable I really think so
too
well I'm already like getting sort of
breathing anxiety just watching you do
this me I listen to you because there's
a big puddle here then you've got to
keep my breathing hose above the water
line now it's between me breathing you
can't last it was your life life like if
I die because my breathing hose comes
unattached the cardboard box you used to
play the war I would not be better
please it's alright I think it'd be safe
I'll keep it on the box
alright
no way can you still hit if you still
breathe uh-huh all right so I'm gonna
just tie off now this is one of the
strangest things I've ever done and I'm
sure at the same time is one of the
strangest things you've ever done okay
how well can you hear me if I talk right
here be okay I am going to insert the
device all right I guess don't cover
your face and pop it somewhere behind
your head it's sunny right now if you
want to go for it
here we are
oh you can totally see the split there
as well yeah that whoa so if you're
wondering why it's actually very dark
it's because the widest aperture on this
lens is an f-14 which is many stops
underexposed but that's all we can get
it with this lens is not really another
lens I have like a big hunk of the war I
mean that is pretty awesome but I did
actually just cover my face yeah when I
said papi I said you know try and do it
without covering your face look away
there's so many things on my mind like
not drowning not drowning continuing to
live I wish I was filming at just normal
speed when I came into the balloon cuz I
went in I focused up but I couldn't see
anything and then I just saw you like a
baby in a womb like this but also when
it popped because I had my lens through
the ring of the balloon yeah the
immediate release of stress on the rest
of the balloon just made the whole girl
like that so I my camera was like look
so I wasn't expecting that which I
should have been so let's try it again
yeah you compensate more for the balloon
popping and I won't cover my idiot face
okay so now we're switching to a blue
balloon because we've run out of clear
ones unfortunately and it was already
kind of dark in the clear one so I think
because the blue is going to be
filtering out all wavelengths of light
except blue we're gonna have even less
light than before so what I'm going to
do is instead of decreasing the frame
rate to make it brighter I'm just going
to increase the shutter speed from a 180
degree to a 360 degree I don't usually
do it because it makes a load of motion
blur but we really need the stops
without seeing the balloon this is a
weird site are you just doing me good
[Music]
this has got to be a fetish for some
people then a film as they come in yep
yep cameras burning me the camera yeah
bloody third-degree burn on my hand look
at the red put your hand up here yeah
and I was doing this to hold it right
yeah
Oh Oh No it's like I didn't know if I
burnt myself oh my ass is hot on this
tripod everything's black everything
that this black is really hot playing
back see me there yeah I really like the
way this one popped a lot more and then
immediately I was out of the water you
were out the water and there you can see
it it looks like an actual wave like
you've just been filming in a way it
looks like a Titan waking up yeah yeah
it really makes a difference to me yeah
yeah that was good I like that one and
I'm glad we didn't go down in framerate
and where we kept mm yeah it's a blurry
thousand but I think it still looks
great but I think we need less because
it's still only a couple of frames where
it's where you're sort of in there and
is ripped so I think that last one was
great you didn't cover your face it
looked amazing but we still have this
gammy old one that was all stuck to
itself and I kinda want to see if it
works
I took it in the bath and I sort of gave
it a good talking-to and hopefully it's
gonna actually be all right oh yeah I
don't think this I don't think this one
that was all stuck to itself he's gonna
work nice and lemon you don't need flex
tape flex tape
phlex yeah that's a lot of damage I've
heard that's a lot of damage before I
don't want it's fraud
sorry that's alright do you care you
applied it like flight state I mean I'm
really really just another pole we don't
even know about holes underneath is this
what white people do oh you doing what
are you doing believe it take the leaf
out take it out there's a there's a leaf
in there proceeds to not remove it it's
hard to put it's like trying to put a
tie on someone else it's actually harder
yeah you just you just never get used to
doing this this has never felt like a
second nature to me it's for sure
backwards
yes yeah yep
oh yes wicked it's still absolutely
flunked me down it's like extra whiplash
that time see all draining away from the
inside I'm impressed with how quickly
the lens cleared it's like a hydrophobic
coating on the front by the looks of it
because it just immediately is gone
there's crazy to see perfectly well and
that light like once it's pop gives some
nice reflection - I just love it back
then I wonder if the focus changes when
the walk goes way it must do like the
refraction means that I'm focused in a
different place wow I can't believe we
got that done we usually have absolutely
no crew for all of our normal videos you
know youtuber originals aside and now we
absolutely could have used crew today
that was a lot of work for two people
there was so much going on at the same
time what to think about love logistics
having someone underwater in a balloon
and shoving a camera into it and what
honestly once you're inside the balloon
I actually felt a bit alone I had to do
everything I was I do it all the lights
in like feeding the air hose and the
water pipe and the lens and tie it off
and reach in my hand into a 90 degree
bag was it hard to hear what I was
saying no it's pretty easy to understand
me yeah I couldn't really hear you
unless you you stood right next to the
bag it was like quite different the
worst thing is that the Phantom was in a
black unventilated bag which thankfully
they're very rugged cameras and can
survive but my skin did not survive
holding the handle for an extended
period I'm impressed with you compared
you've got burned you physically were
burning yourself I'd like holding the
camera
well we've successfully done another
giant balloon G video I hope you enjoyed
it feel free to leave an idea in the
comments for what we should do next June
and make sure you subscribe ring the
bell and all that second Channel
we'll see you very soon can't believe
you did it with the bus the last balloon
I know I was like oh I'll just jokingly
tape in her flight area and then I ended
up getting in it and doing it I'm
exhausted
yeah me too my legs are like shaking
like them because I'm just
I almost got cramp in there I was like
oh god no because I'd pop the balloon
yeah you're player yeah that's good